APPROPRIATIONS WILL COME TO
ORDER- GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME
TO THE FIRST HEARING IN THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE FOR
THE TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO LEGISLATIVE SESSION.
I SHOULD. BANG MY GAVEL SO
SPECIAL. IN RESPONSE THE COVE
IN NINETEEN EMERGENCY TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO THE NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. EARLIER COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH OUR VICE CHAIR SENATOR
BATES PARTICIPATING REMOTELY.
SENATOR BATES IF YOU HAVE STAFF
IN THE ROOM WITH YOU COULD YOU
PLEASE IDENTIFY THAT PERSON OR
IF YOU'RE ALONE LET US KNOW. I
DO HAVE STAFF- IT IS. UNDER
REARED ONE OF MY LEGISLATIVE
AIDES. THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
AND OBVIOUSLY PUT YOUR
MICROPHONE BACKGROUND MUSIC
WHICH WILL ELIMINATE ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK I ASKED THAT EVERY
TIME YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED
THAT YOU RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM- AND
THAT'LL ALLOW US TO. SEE THE
POP UP WINDOW AND ALLOW US TO
RECOGNIZE YOU- AND OBVIOUSLY HE
ACT ON YOU BEFORE SPEAKING R.
I. T. PERSON WILL PUT YOU BACK.
ON MUTE WHEN YOU'RE DONE AND
ONCE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU CAN
BE SEEN ON THE SCREEN STATE
YOUR NAME AND THAT YOU ARE
READY TO ADDRESS. THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
LISTINGS ALLOW ALLOWS US. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT TO PARTICIPATE
CALL TOLL FREE NUMBER. AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL ALSO
BE DISPLAYED ON SCREEN AND ALL
AMOUNTS IT NOW. SO TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR I'LL SAY IT
AGAIN. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE
ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS SIX FIVE FOUR.
TWO EIGHT NINE SEVEN AGAIN THE
TWO EIGHT NINE SEVEN AND FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO
TELECONFERENCE WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE AND OR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION. PRESSES
ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER. THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT- ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
AWAITING THE CAN. IN THE QUEUE
FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR
LINE NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU
WILL BE ON MUTED AND YOU ARE
NOW READYTO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE IN ORDER
FOR US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND
TO AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE AGAIN IF
YOU'RE GOING TO BE SPEAKING.
TURNED THE MEANS BUTTON ON
WHATEVER DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING
HEARING. I WILL MAKE TRYING TO
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS CUSTOMARY AN
INDIVIDUAL ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
DISRUPTS. MAY BE- SHUT OFF FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTION MUTED.
IT'S ALSO A GOOD TIME TO REMIND
EVERYONE PROVIDING TESTIMONY
THAT THIS IS A FISCAL
COMMITTING. SO PLEASE LIMIT
YOUR TESTIMONY TO FISCAL
ASPECTS OF THE BILL YOUR
TESTIMONY YOUR TESTIFYING ON
AND PLEASE REFRAIN FROM RE
LITIGATING. THE POLICY MERITS
OF THE BILL BECAUSE. THIS IS A-
FISCAL. COMMITTEE WELL EVERY
HAS BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE
HEARING PROCESSING CONDUCTOR
HEARINGS IN THIS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNERS CUSTOMARY THERE
MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS ARE ALL GOING TO
TRY TO BE. PATIENT WERE ALSO-
FOR THE BILL WE HAVE ONE BILL
UP TODAY SB TWENTY NINE BY
SENATOR UMBERG. WHEN WE HEAR
FROM CENTER NUMBER AGAIN I WILL
TAKE- ONE PRIMARY WITNESS FOR.
AND ONE PRIMARY WITNESS AGAINST
AND I WILL ALLOW THREE MINUTES
FOR THE PRIMARY WITNESSES IF
THERE IS A PRIMARY WITNESS. AND
THEN ALL SUBSEQUENT TESTIMONY
WILL BE A ME TO SWITCH WILL BE
LIMITED TO YOUR NAME. OR IN AN
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR SUPPORT
OR OPPOSE POSITION FOR ALL OF
THE- SUBSEQUENT COMMENTS WE
WILL NOT BE TAKING- COMMENTS
BEYOND NAME ORGANIZATION AND
YOUR POSITION- BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATION ON THE BILL LET'S
ESTABLISH OUR QUORUM SO MR
SECRETARY IF YOU COULD CALL.
THE ROLL SO WE CAN ESTABLISH
OUR QUORUM. SENATOR PORTANTINO
I'M HERE PORTANTINO HERE
SENATOR BATES. AIR CANADA BATES
IS HERE BRADFORD. EFFORT HERE
JONES JONES HERE LAYERED. BLAIR
HERE BY CASTING DUSKY HERE TO
COURT. WE HAVE A QUORUM SO.
OKAY WE ARE GOING TO HEAR FROM
SENATOR TOM BURKE ABOUT SB
TWENTY NINE WELCOME SENATOR
AMBURGEY MAY PRESENT YOUR BILL
AND- PROCEED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN SENATORS
THE S. B. TWENTY NINE. SIMPLY
TAKES SOME OF THE PROVISIONS
THAT WERE ENACTED- BECAUSE OF
THE COVERT CRISIS IN THE
NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY ELECTION
AN INCORPORATES THEM INTO
SPECIAL ELECTIONS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE PROVIDES THAT EVERY
REGISTERED ACTIVE VOTERS IN THE
DISTRICTS IN WHICH SPECIAL
ELECTIONS WILL BE HELD WILL
RECEIVE A MAIL IN BALLOT- THE
ELECTION IN NOVEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY ACTUALLY WORKED OUT
QUITE WELL SO FOR A COUPLE
IRREGULARITIES OF PRIMARILY AND
IN ORANGE COUNTY. WE HAVE THE
HIGHEST VOTER TURNOUT SINCE
PRESIDENT TRUMAN WAS IN OFFICE-
IN COUNTRY CONVENTION WAS A
MIGHT NOT BODE NOT OFTEN THAT
ELECTION UP IN THIS PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL SAFETY FOR BOTH
VOTERS AS WELL AS ELECTION
WORKERS AYE URGENT AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MICHON BURKE- IS
THERE DO YOU HAVE ANY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT- WE HAVE NO
WITNESSES OUR LIVES RIGHT
MISTER CHAIR. THE OLD HABITS
DIE HARD HELLO THERE IS THERE
IS THERE A LAWYER IN THE HOUSE.
RIGHT REALLY. IS THERE A- ANY
WITNESSES ONLINE IN SUPPORT.
I'M NOT AWARE OF ANY MISTER ALL
RIGHT IS THERE ANYONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE IN SUPPORT. SEEING
NONE I'M SORRY ISRAEL YES IS
THERE ANYONE IN THIS ROOM IN
SUPPORT. SEEING NONE ALL RIGHT
IS THERE A PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION. IN THIS ROOM I SEE
NO ONE. THE. YES SHOULD WE GO
TO THE CONFERENCE LINE IN
SUPPORT. YEAH ASSEMBLY THERE'S
NOBODY RIGHT YEAH THIRTY TO.
ALL RIGHT THERE'S NO. YOU
SHOULD HAVE IN ORDER TO CHECK
THE MODERATORS OR ANYONE IN THE
CONFERENCE LINE IN SUPPORT. IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WHAT I HAVE NO LINES
INTO AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
THERE'S NOBODY IN ON THE
CONFERENCE LINE IN SUPPORT WILL
NOW GO TO OPPOSITION THERE'S NO
ONE IN THIS ROOM WHO WISHES TO
BE A PRIMARY WITNESS. NOBODY IN
ROOM. ONE TWELVE. ALL WILL GO
TO THE CONFERENCE LINE.
MODERATORS THEIR OPPOSITION
INSURANCE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE
NO LICENSE YOU AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT SO THERE'S NOBODY HERE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION MISTER
AMBER YOU ARE A MAN STANDING
ALONE ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
FOR THE AUTHOR. I WILL CLOSE
THE PUBLIC COMMENTS IS THERE NO
PUBLIC ANY QUESTIONS FOR THE
DOCTOR. SEEING NO HANDS GO UP
MR UMBERG. WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THE BILL MUCH ROBERT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE YES I URGE YOU TO
VOTE. WE HER FOR AN AYE VOTE-
SO. WE HAVE THE CLOSE WITH THAT
AGAIN THERE WAS NO PUBLIC
COMMENT FOR AGAINST. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON A MOTION BY
MISTER LEARN. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO HI WRITTEN TINO HI
BATES. HE DIDN'T. YOU HEAR ME
YES WE CAN. OKAY STATE YOUR
NAME AND YOUR VOTE. SENATOR PAT
BATES VOTING NO BATES NO
BRADFORD. BRADFORD HI JONES
JONES NO PLAYER BLARED FIVE
BOGEYS THREE TWO VOTE IS THREE
TO TEN. MCALLISTER I'M SORRY
WHAT ELSE MY CALENDAR. BUT
STATE FARM CASKEY I'D LIKE
OWSKI ON- THE VOTE IS FORTY
TWO. MISTER CHAIR IT SENATORS
THE LOTUS FORTY TWO YOUR BILL
IS OUT AND- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
EVERYONE THAT CONCLUDES OUR
BUSINESS I MEAN JUST SAVE ALL
MEMBERS PARTICIPATING FIVE TO
FIVE THE LUNCH MAKE SURE.
THERE'S NO. THANK YOU ALL FOR
THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED TODAY AND IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY YOU
CAN SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS YOUR COMMENTS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WITH THAT THIS
MEETING WILL COME TO.
ADJOURNMENTS.